what I don't like is now you're gonna
say well men suck because of my choice
which didn't doesn't look very good
um I mean again women are supposed to be
loyal for a lifetime that's the original
monogamy is getting married as a virgin
you stay with one guy forever and you
know in history the Kings would have
concubines and multiple women so that's
not really like we can try to rewrite
biology but it's still biology and
whining and crying and saying how you
hate working for bar school stool
publicly like I this is so disrespectful
a platform that's giving you everything
you're gonna say men suck and
I've been feeling attacked